one to lose weight well have a huge bowl
of salad most of us think that by having
salad on a daily basis it can help with
weight loss that is true a huge bowl of
salad contains all the nutrients
vitamins and minerals that your body
needs plus it is very hard to overeat
but what you choose to dress your salad
with can be a killer it can turn a
really healthy meal into a calorie bomb
I'm talking about store-bought salad
dressings which are very high in fat
salt sugar and even additives each
tablespoon has about 70 to 100 calories
this a sneaky calories and they are
probably ruining your diet without you
even realizing it you must be thinking
my salad must be really tasteless and
boring hey make your own salad dressings
instead they are cheap easy to make
healthy and you can control what you put
in it so here are four of my favorite
low-fat salad dressings for a lighter
version always up for vinaigrette based
dressing so my first recipe is the spicy
lime vinaigrette dressing what you'll
need are three tablespoons of lemon
juice three tablespoons of rice wine
vinegar one tablespoon of light soy
sauce half a tablespoon of sesame oil
half a tablespoon of extra virgin olive
oil half a tablespoon of maple syrup one
garlic clove minced and half a teaspoon
of dried chili flakes mix all the
ingredients in a bowl and stir until
well combined
each tablespoon has about 23 calories
drizzle a couple of tablespoons onto
your salad and serve do you know that
one tablespoon of ranch dressing has
about 73 calories the recipe usually
calls for mayonnaise sour cream and
buttermilk for healthy twist we're going
to replace the cream with silken tofu
don't worry guys you will barely taste
the tofu this recipe has under 10
calories per tablespoon it is still
thick creamy and packed with herbs and
spices what you'll need are one cup
of silken tofu 1 tablespoon of lemon
juice quarter teaspoon of garlic powder
quarter teaspoon of dried chives quarter
teaspoon of dried mixed herbs quarter
teaspoon of cayenne pepper and salt and
pepper to taste simply blend the silken
tofu in a blender until smooth then mix
all the ingredients in a bowl and stir
until well combined
well if tofu is not your thing then just
replace it with yogurt who loves as it
key also known as Greek cucumber yogurt
here's a really simple recipe you can
follow so what I've used are half a cup
of yogurt 1/2 a cup of cucumber finely
grated cut a cup of mint leaves finely
chopped 2 teaspoons of lemon juice 1
garlic clove minced and a pinch of salt
and pepper again simply mix all the
ingredients in a bowl you can choose to
chill in the fridge before serving each
quarter cup only has about 28 calories
it's refreshing creamy and zingy I like
to dip it with some chopped up
vegetables such as cucumbers carrots and
even celery or you can choose to serve
it with some bread and even grilled meat
if you love Tomatoes try this final
recipe to mutter vinaigrette what you'll
need are have a can of diced tomatoes
cut a cup of shallots diced 1 garlic
clove minced one-and-a-half tablespoons
of apple cider vinegar 2 tablespoons of
extra-virgin olive oil a pinch of
cayenne pepper and a pinch of salt and
pepper
in a bowl add all the ingredients mix
well and serve each tablespoon has about
21 calories this flavorful tomato
vinaigrette is not only great with salad
it is also delicious with roasted
vegetables grilled meat seafood or serve
it as a dip the next time you enjoy a
bowl of salad just be really aware of
the dressing choose to serve it on the
side and enjoy in small quantities or
make your own instead so try all these
recipes out and let me know which is
your favorite in the comments below tag
at Joanna's are official and hashtag
chaser recipes guys like this video
share this video and subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more healthy
recipes workout videos and also fitness
tips do turn on your notification button
so that you will get notified every time
I share a new video all the best